From charity here on the ground as you
can see behind me this is a home that
has been destroyed by the earthquake
what I have in my hand is our food pack
that we are giving to these victims that
have been suffering from the earthquake
my brothers and  sisters we need your
support you know these brothers and
sisters what they do is they've come
together as a community and made a
communal kitchen where they can cook
this stuff this is why we give out
milk tomato py tea sugar oil flour so
they can  make themselves food
[music] Oh
God, you see the conditions that have befallen us in Gaza,
O God of glory and glory, O God of power and glory, O God, honor the people of Gaza, O God, help the people, O God,
relieve the people of Gaza, O God, make the people of Gaza happy, O God, grant victory to the people of Gaza, O God,
heal their wounded, O
God, heal their sick  O God, accept their martyr, O
God, have mercy on their
dead, O God, heal their wounds and
heal their pain, O God, and grant them and the Muslims a quick relief, O God, O God, relieve us and the Muslims everywhere, O God, grant victory to Islam, honor the Muslims,
abandon polytheism and the polytheists, and destroy the enemies of religion, O Lord of
the worlds. Glory be to You, Glory be to You. You see the oppressors, so be patient
so that they think that you are neglecting them.  You test the righteous in
this world until all of them despair, and if they despair, you will bring them victory.
O God, you know that the wounds of Muslims
are many and their pain is many in every place at every
time. O God, grant us victory over our enemies, O God, O
God, so make our feet firm,
O God.